[Music]
Comcast 40 seconds of unnecessary logos
for wholly unnecessary sequel just like
two peas in an unnecessary pod I'd give
good money if the Mandarin from Iron Man
3 showed up right now raining helicopter
missiles down on this Oceanside mansion
and laugh all you want about the
ludicrous crossover idea but still in
skarsgård is in this he was in the
Avengers and don't forget Dominic Cooper
was also Howard Stark in the First
Avenger
thanks Singh writing thank you for the
music look Amanda cipher it is a lovely
actress her voice is average certainly
not worth devoting the first minute of a
film to an acapella performance
featuring her and her alone I know these
movies aren't about good singing but
maybe they should be pleasure and
privilege will be mine Andy Garcia's
featured in no more than 3% of the total
run time of the movie cliche wish I
could ask her she died off-camera she
never shows up anyway sure you've gone
to the trouble to name address and add
postage to this invitation and there's
no downside to letting it get to its
destination
but let's rip the fuck out of that
sucker for reasons that aren't even
dramatic enough to carry the plot of
this movie she's going to do good eight
things Donna well I don't know about
great Pierce Brosnan sure and you could
maybe talk me into Colin Firth after a
few cocktails but stellan skarsgård I'm
not saying I'd kick him out of bed but I
am saying this is a little forward from
your Scholastic mentors for her
valedictorian speech she sings a song
about kissing a teacher and the students
go wild and I want to punch this movie
in the knee with a steel glove man this
one I kissed the teacher number was
dated even before this fucking movie
came out I know we got a dig in to
ABBA's back catalogue for songs for the
second movie but Jesus when you're
determined to stick to that only Alba
songs rule you set for yourself you end
up with awkward like this yeah and I
remember when our top student crowd
surfed at our graduation that was rad
salutatorian got his ass dropped when he
tried that though not a song is so
infectious they all leave graduation
without getting their diplomas and go on
a sing-along bike ride through town and
if they were all Muppets fine but
they're not Muppets they're humans so
not fine she can come mother damn even
if your mom is cher it's a little weird
to be this knowledgeable about her sex
life if you just graduated from school
and live in this apartment with your
best friends you were not allowed to
complain about Jack or God Harry Osborn
from the Raimi spider-man films called
and wants to trade his penthouse for
this one that's how absurd this flat is
so much of this movie is flashback they
should
that mama mia here we went again cuz
weird yeah well we agreed six weeks in
New York learning the hotel business
from the very best I know anytime I'm on
a long-distance call with my romantic
partner there's nothing sexier than hot
steamy exposition so if you mom died a
year ago do boyfriend fell Christ how
did you even make it this far you idiot
take care yeah you too sky you know when
I realized this relationship was doomed
when I discovered the guy's name was sky
look I'm sure there are some super fans
of ABBA out there whether it's due to
the music or the palindromic name but
does anyone really have a massive music
boner for one of us
I can't demonstrate the quality of
Dominic Cooper singing here but just
trust me when I describe it as somewhere
between drunk late-night open mic at a
bar in Sacramento and the role of
Captain Von Trapp in a third grade
presentation to the sound of music does
this hell it's holding a candle but it's
made entirely of wood and I have to
believe it's Satan's irony Lantern
designed to make you die by lighting a
single match he says hell what is this
buried this is ten times it alarming is
that fat ass cartoon whores and Mary
Poppins we have to be strong for in case
you were worried that this movie
wouldn't repeat the exact same beats as
the first one here's a scene that could
literally be from that movie so two of
your three possible fathers can't make
it Christ
yes he's still my fitting vagina
screenplay by jokes rejected for Amy
Schumer's latest mailed in stand-up
special you know the courage of a lion
the passion of the Panther no wisdom
will mingle
dude slipped on the final analogy and
killed the cat trifecta oh yeah I
remember that origin story for Donna
that was briefly mentioned then
forgotten about for the last section of
the movie yeah I mean either really
doesn't make a difference though since
none of this movie makes a goddamn lick
of sense waiting only three seconds
between dinging the Bell is a sign of
entitled impatience dinging Matt
frequent is obnoxious and people used to
think if you sailed on from there you'd
fall off the edge it used to think used
to years ago my mom was in Central
America and she had her heart broken
little pieces now I'm only gonna break
your heart and scatter exploded into a
million little pieces whether or not you
get it all together will be Finders
Keepers losers weepers it appears I may
have been caught unawares in a moment of
spontaneous luda impersonating my
apologies he's playing a French baguette
as an air guitar and then also as a
fucking trumpet this class photo ham
dance can lick my dirty man panties the
lyrics at the end of the chorus are
literally Waterloo knowing my fate is to
be with you so this song is equated a
career-ending staggering battle loss
with a relationship meaning she's not
happy to be stuck with your ass dude
feels like defeat the song is about the
desperation of realizing you've been in
a marriage for 20 years and you're stuck
in it now even though it's making you
miserable
Bob the movie wants to make it a happy
puppy love Rob what even the fuck
Clutton so after that song she decided
to fuck him man all the times I was
rejected in bars in my youth when all I
had to do was sing an Abba song cutting
from post coital flashback cuddles to
the daughter here between two of her
dead moms snoozing friends awkward is
movie the bed is literally the only
thing connecting the two shots it's a
special night not for morning but for
celebration that's how mom would have
wanted it are we talking about the
opening of the hotel or a funeral for
your mom she is a drunk indeed and
danced until she dropped on John scene
Queen roll credits
wait movie clearly didn't learn from its
predecessor about the dangers of letting
pierce brosnan sing holy Sh no wonder
Donna's gone she obviously discovered
Sam had these pictures of a scantily
clad Lily James and it shocked her to
death what would be really great in this
Harbor there was a guy young tall
dashingly handsome just kind of blond
Jared let it was right
you should board his boat there are two
beds but unfortunately one of them's
rather full I asked the old I cannot
possibly move this off this other bed so
you better bunk with me routine this is
more transparent horniness than when
Bart's babysitter's boyfriend Jimbo said
now my pants are chafing me I get it
you're one of them that's probably
racist but what I'm most struck by is
the only way the scene could be any
wider as if powder were on the boat crew
you've already committed too many sins
to be considered excellent at cinema
since nobody has time for this this is
about to jump in to save people that
cannot swim and he takes off his light
ass
shirt but leaves on his heavy-ass jeans
don't you worry I have made my peace
with pain I admire Andy's attitude here
not everyone could get over Geo storm
this quickly the storm is coming and
movies can stop with the storm is coming
imagery it's really annoying there's a
storm coming weather-wise and an
emotional storm as well get it dawn is
coming
god damn it even in a flashback story
how did domina I guess she just saw the
future Oh even Donna couldn't have
predicted the first movie would have
made over 600 million worldwide breaking
and entering in case the movie thought
it a lien Aidid its core demographic it
turns into an HGTV episode right in the
middle this is the fastest moving storm
in history it's faster than a fucking
Ferrari storm is moving over a hundred
miles an hour god damn in an otherwise
abandoned complex she finds a fucking
horse and not only that it's a horse in
peril a horse hankering for a helping
hand from a hot human harmonizer who
happens to be hanging about is there
seriously no contingency plan for a pink
storm around here I mean even if they
don't have an often it should be pretty
easy to contend with right
I'd consider removing at least five sins
if Prince's when doves cry we're playing
right now alas well no guys just met
like I don't know today I mean how long
has it been since the graduation
ceremony a couple of days and a few
buddies ago
first of all holy those are some large
ass grape baskets those are hot air
balloon baskets and he's converted them
into grape baskets and second of all how
the f does he get these fuckers here to
the town square does he drag them
hunched over one at a time hoping no one
steals the other three unattended
baskets it's even strong enough to pull
one of these pink things grapes are
light relatively speaking but this many
of anything would be heavy as hell just
count waingro here's karaoke routine is
gonna haunt my forever dog nice of Sam
to wait to consummate this relationship
until a good and proper Bruce Almighty
moon presented itself and the most
defined and oversaturated Bruce Almighty
moon in all of history someone opened up
Photoshop or should I call it a Bruce
Almighty Sun no moon ever reflected off
water that fucking brightly this is one
of those shot in daylight and then
dimmed to mimic midnight scenes that's
why they put so much definition on the
moon because they were painting it
digitally onto the Sun well we
transitioned from a nighttime kiss to
abode among the rocks why is the boat
among the rocks did you launch it from
here did you steer into these rocks and
have to navigate your way out I think he
just wanted rocks in your shot and you
told common sense to sucker because of
the storm last night no flights have
come in to Athens at all the storm
lasted for well less than a minute
it had caused minor damage they're
suspending all the flights into Athens
it really is over everybody she's like a
hypochondriac of emotions isn't she I
feel like her therapist could trademark
the phrase that escalated quickly oh
yeah how goat for those of you who were
dying for an origin story about Sam and
Donna's fledgling relationship which
lasted a week my to you your wish is a
universals command in case you confused
it for Tokyo Greece I'd like to thank
what a fat suit on a twin skarsgård
what's that necessary for this story is
anything in this movie necessary or did
the pitch meeting go exactly like that
key and Peele gremlins to sketch you
might think I'm going to send the amount
of luggage but I'm not I'm sitting the
color coordination of the luggage with
each lady's outfit dragging ass then
sing about to what you are feeling even
if it's ultimately guilt for accepting a
paycheck to play a whisper thin part in
it whisper thin movie on location in the
middle of paradise one that required you
to only memorize the lyrics for your
dialogue ready go movie officially waves
the white flag of trying to give us
anything original by literally singing
the title song again I think one of the
most sinful things about this movie is
the casual wireless mics in the 1970s on
a rural Greek island yes the technology
existed at the time but come the fuck on
these are 1999 mics and a 1970 scene so
she sang herself better look I'm a
believer in the power of music but Donna
was seriously down in the dumps like
five seconds ago but now she's
gallivanting with half the town singing
about her newfound strength and now I'm
taking out to sea again your boat or
Donna might be the first boat pronoun
game I've encountered in many many years
of sitting films he's not picking up I
can't even tell him how wrong it's all
gone I can't even tell if this is a true
G storyline or if they just needed a
boat excuse to keep cutting back to the
present and getting Christine horn and
ski some screen time I feel pretty
confident sitting anyone that ever put a
cucumber slice over their eyelid
thinking it was going to provide
anything other than moisture and
self-esteem Spa is over but these dudes
start giving back rubs due to some kind
of choreographically compulsion
they're singing I must let my fingers
dance it's the island okay now I thought
the white squallin wiped it off the face
of the earth yesterday and that it would
take an act of God to be able to put
back together but here's the staff
dutifully standing around while Sophie
bitches about her husband instead of
sprucing things up for the reopening
that could totally still happen what are
the odds - might be Sophie dad's show up
to the ferry dock after last-minute
changes of heart regarding attending the
grand opening of the hotel your might be
daughter is reopening in the honor of
the woman you both definitely
literally the handsomest man in the
world right except for this guy Jesus
one that's clearly known for its
diversity and its realistic depiction of
the human condition without a doubt I
know who you looking for
with your wandering eye and restless
groin movie way to spoil the title of my
upcoming medical drama that was going to
debut on CW this spring man has so many
notch on his bedpost the bed fall down
your ex-girlfriend is fucking a dude
that's an insane amount of women so
there ah finally he found passage on the
I really screwed up and it probably
screwed forever fairy its renowned for
its timeliness few movie no one could
lay on a stray flipper without feeling
it right away I guess maybe the joke is
she's on dudes boat that had all the on
the one bed that one time but I'm Way
too sick of this to care about that kind
of joke at this point just end it's a
little trick I learned faced with a
problem you literally strap yourself
down can't get up until it's sold Fifty
Shades a go ahead many pics all of us
there's not stay at all like pigs just
go ready Christ I'm tired of the
rationalizing conversational games she
liked sex it's not a bad thing so let's
get on with the story such as it may be
is a difficult base for them boats lay
idle and we drink in Georgia surrenders
to our economic whore whore here's an
excuse for the guys to get to the island
but man this casual reference to the
downfall of the Grecian fishing economy
is depressing as hell guy in chair with
hands bound falls into water move he
does it for laughs but I'm thinking he
did for sure I'm beginning to think my
soul mate may actually be carbs his mind
must be wine now I see that the script
was 90% comprised of clever sayings you
find on decorative dish towels at a gift
shop makes much more sense Jesus lady
they're coming for an island vacation
they seen Dunkirk these assholes again
are performing marine dancing queen
which means they preen instead of clean
in advance of this Byzantine scene of
saccharine Libertines that are all
keenly on Dramamine and for this obscene
routine they receive 15 dings these
boats are dangerously over capacity
this goes on for fucking forever
let's see here the party arrived sky and
Sophie are back together and the three
men are with their little lady anything
else okay you're wrapped up then there's
seriously 30 minutes left the party is
still happening look after the fireworks
I'm pretty sure Andi Garcia took this
job so that he could tour all the golf
courses in Croatia and only showed up on
set while his clubs were being regripped
thank heavens all three dads made it
here on time I for one am super but make
it beautiful you can stay for free Donna
somehow works out a better deal than the
rent control book on friends know what
that means yeah but there's also a lot
of shellfish at this hotel I mean I'm
just saying no need to immediately jump
to conclusions with emotion
noise Wow pregnancy also gives you
superhuman hearing be able to make out
an approaching helicopter from what
looks like easily 3 to 4 miles away over
the noise of the party these two
carrying their own luggage down the hill
is the biggest lie in the film now we're
gonna do the whole pair up random folks
for sex just for laughs ending let the
party commence King Cher take them there
I'll be leaving that out of the pile of
all the unnecessary bullsh in this movie
and cramming share in at the very end
might be the most unnecessary us by far
an entire songs worth of footage of
Donna's labor porch movie Porsche skip
no lie legit forgot Andy Garcia was in
this movie whatever movies need them
multi-million dollar fireworks displays
appear on demand I a you to look
obscenely famous yes turn my frown
upside down
wow she does have access to all the best
doctors with disability so I guess he
was in good hands
despite only appearing in this movie for
about three minutes Meryl Streep was
reflexively nominated for an Academy
Award movie ends on several minutes of
Cher doing Abba karaoke and that's it
folks I'm out of here I have to draw the
line somewhere damn it
now my pants are shaking me and how
lovely to see all your bright happy
faces smiling up at me
he is the life of parties he has never
attended if he were to punch you in the
face he would have to fight off the
strong urge to thank him do what makes
your soul shine
[Music]